[Aplausos]
la igualdad de género nunca ha sido
presente en el ecuador por varias
razones culturales religiosas y hasta
por la capacidad que tiene cada
individuo
cuando nosotros somos pequeños
no hay ningún límite a lo que podemos
hacer y lo que podemos lograr en nuestra
vida
hasta que los adultos nos lo impongan
no somos chiquitos nosotros jugamos con
todo jugamos con los zapatos de nuestras
mamás con las almohadas con cajas en fin
todo lo que está a nuestro alrededor
pero a medida que crecemos
estos objetos empiezan a limitar y
empiezan a ser controlados
para que nuestro primer año de colegio
nosotros ya sabemos lo que debe ser una
mujer y lo que debe hacer un hombre y
tenemos tan solo cuatro años
cuando yo entré a pre kinder me
sorprendió encontrar encontrarme con una
barrera imaginaria entre las canchas de
fútbol de los hombres y las casitas de
las mujeres
y para los cumpleaños todos tenemos un
tema los hombres con sus motos con sus
carros con sus superhéroes todo lo
masculino
y las mujeres con sus princesitas sus
dadas y todo lo rosado en fin todo lo
femenino
pero me puso a pensar como como puede
ser esto
y cómo podemos nosotros cambiar y cómo
pueden las instituciones cambiar
es tan simple cuando estamos en pekín de
nosotros necesitamos ayuda de los
mayores todavía no somos independientes
los profesores se tienen que enfocar en
quitar la idea de que todo objeto tiene
un género y que es de hecho para un
género
tenemos que enfocarnos en que los
chiquitos lean libros con personajes
principales del otro género que jueguen
con todos los juguetes que hayan en la
clase y que el recreo no exista una
barrera entre los juegos
en la primaria
en la primaria nos separamos porque los
hombres apestas y las mujeres dan asco
entonces cómo vamos a lograr aquí cuando
existe esta separación esta falta de
comunicación entre los géneros cómo
asegurarnos de que haya alguna igualdad
obviamente nos recreos no nos vamos a
acercar a uno del otro entonces esos
profesores tienen que encontrar una
manera de que exista una comunicación
entre hombres y mujeres
y es tan simple como decir parejas
hombre y mujer que siempre haya un
balance en en las mesas que siempre haya
un balance en proyectos grupales y que
en fin siempre exista una idea de que
todos los estudiantes en el aula puedan
ser grandes que puedan lograr cosas sean
mujeres hombres
la secundaria la secundaria tal vez es
el lugar al que ninguno de nosotros
quiere volver a menos que esas fiestas
sin los estudios
pero también es el lugar donde nosotros
empezamos a pensar en nuestro futuro
empezamos a pensar lo que queremos
lograr cuando seamos grandes o como
queremos cambiar el mundo
pero no lo podemos hacer si es que
también en este tiempo de nuestra vida
existen mucho más los roles de los
géneros
yo no creo en los colegios de solo
mujeres o solo hombres y aunque en
varios estudios demuestran que los
estudiantes del mejor rendimiento en
estos ámbitos escolásticos me parece que
en fin la sociedad nos funciona con un
solo género la sociedad funciona con los
géneros trabajando juntos para lograr un
mejor mañana
pero me parece que a base de varios
varias investigaciones nosotros podemos
en las áreas científicas separar hombres
y mujeres ya que demuestra que no
empieza cuando son separados ya no
existe tanta competencia entre los
géneros si no existe competencia entre
el mismo género y ayuda para que todos
los alumnos dentro de la clase den mejor
rendimiento pero también existe el
compañerismo
pero no solo es el deber de las
instituciones
es nuestro deber como las futuras
generaciones como las generaciones que
van a estar encargados de todos los
ministerios que van a estar en como
profesores de las aulas como abogados
nosotros tenemos el deber de también
cambiar y cambiar en este momento
como lo vamos a hacer
nosotros empezamos cuando entramos a la
secundaria a usar muchas frases muchas
frases que lo decimos porque así hemos
crecido es una frase que todos la
conocemos
pero deberíamos parar de usarlas
un gran ejemplo es
a un hombre le puede gustar el ballet a
un hombre le puede gustar el color
rosado
y a un hombre le pueden gustar las
películas románticas más que las
películas de acción
pero no tiene derecho a ser llamado
por parte de nuestra
sabiendo que eso podría cambiar su vida
en el futuro sabiendo que eso va a
determinar lo que va a lograr en su
futuro
y no es sólo hacia los hombres
una de las frases más usadas creado
hacia las mujeres desde que entre la
secundaria es es que esté en el mes
i
les cuento existen varios estudios que
dicen que
es mucho más predecible
cómo va a actuar una mujer o cómo se va
a sentir emocionalmente dependiendo del
día de la semana el mes del año y hasta
la hora en el día
no es su culpa que usen estas frases
pero tienen el poder en sus manos de
parar de usarlas
nosotros debemos empezar a entender que
es una cuestión de falta de comunicación
nosotros debemos de empezar a hablar
a decir y simplemente asegurarnos de que
todos sabemos cómo se siente una persona
y como nosotros podemos hacer que no le
estemos limitando en su futuro
entonces mi querida generación les pido
cuando estén con un grupo de personas
están a punto de decir esa frase esta
frase que ustedes saben
que no debería ser usadas piensen dos
veces
sólo piense en cómo esa pequeña frase va
a cambiar la vida de esa persona y no lo
digan
solo traten de asegurarse que en este
momento el momento en el que tenemos el
poder en nuestras manos para cambiar la
vida de las futuras generaciones para
que ellos no tengan que pasar lo que
nosotros estamos pasando asegúrense de
que están tomando que están tomando esta
oportunidad
entonces
lo único que les pido
es pensar y preguntar y comunicarse
gracias